así es pues hubo muchísima fiesta sobre
todo en las arcas del centro de lisboa
porque ustedes saben los o partidos se
juegan sin un público por causa de la
corona vídeos así que los cientos de
parisinos que están aquí en a lisboa
festejaron y luego pues llevaron toda
esa fiesta al hotel del parís a sandra
amaya dicen algunos unos astados unos
200 aparecidos que esperaron el regreso
de su equipo de sus héroes que como
ustedes bien lo decía pues se
clasificaron a la final de la liga de
campeones por primera vez en sus 50 años
de historia y ahora pues están esperando
saber quién va a ser ese contrincante
que tendrán en el estadio andaluz en
este próximo domingo en esta final tan
esperada para parís y sobre todo para
los qataríes detrás del equipo que han
hecho una gran inversión para llegar
hasta aquí mejor nada casi histórica por
lo que cuentas para los fanáticos del
parís saint germain natalia que se
espera del partido de esta noche que se
va a disputar entre el bayern múnich y
el olympique de lyon
así después es la otra semifinal que
también es franco-alemana estos dos
equipos ya se han enfrentado al menos
nueve veces en liga de campeones y pues
siempre digamos que es el bayern munich
quien ha sacado provecho de esto el
bayern munich espera tener de nuevo el
título de campeones de europa algo que
no consiguen desde 2013 pero el
olympique lyonnais ha hecho una gran
campaña en esta liga de campeones
llegando hasta la hasta la semifinal en
octavos eliminó a la juventus de turín
en cuartos eliminó al manchester city-
de pep guardiola así que viene con
muchísima fuerza y pues el bayern munich
ustedes saben vino como una máquina de
matar y le dio esa goleada al barcelona
en cuartos de final así que vamos a ver
si este domingo será una final
completamente francesa o una final
franco-alemana estaremos muy pendientes
natalia de lo que suceda en la semifinal
de hoy en la final del domingo por
supuesto muchísimas gracias por este
reporte desde portugal